oi oi
[Música]
[Aplausos]
oi oi
a foto de pessoal daqui é que a gente
fala dar que sejam muito bem vindos a
mais um vídeo porque tu os dois relógios
não é para as horas ou três minutos
Então pessoal estragos aqui ainda não
sei calma espera coisas que vais vir
pelo primeiro não coisas que tu vais ver
pela primeira vez na tua vida algo assim
algo assim olha lá pessoal Olha aí temos
aqui já um atleta
um OK eu não não não não não eu nunca
Como assim eu só estou muito alto meu
Isto é tipo que um metro um metro e 10
de salto sem balanço só WhatsApp eu vou
tentar não só consegui 20 vendidos
Oi ok
e como é que ela não partiu a costela
ela tá impossível impossível Ok entrou
no carro pela janela isso é normal já
tinha visto isso só entro não assim
assim tão suave eu nunca desliguei eu só
entro 1
e no ato que é que está a passar aqui
eu estou aqui pesca radical ele está a
piscar ou está na fábrica onde já
buscaram os peixes tipo estão a fazer a
seleção Imaginem lixeira peixe O Peixe
Podre que tá não é tão vivos e não-vivos
motherfuck impressionante Ok Isso é o
que
e é isso olha público Aposto que vocês
nunca viram esse na vossa vida
fabricação de cubos de rubik Olha aí o
famoso cubo mágico Bora lá próximo
o Ok estou uma máquina de choque as
parece aqueles Plus mas não é i.a. exato
um OK eu e já tinha visto isso não me
impressionou tanto que quando vocês a
próxima uma lâmpada um destes aparelhos
de plasma ela Tecnicamente acende né
acontece estou a ver o que é que vai
sair daqui ao meu Deus Beyblade humano é
isso é fácil sempre que eu consigo fazer
isso aqui ó
E aí
já viram é fácil vai fácil Ok temos aqui
um que um artista de metro olha como ele
dança outro é
e eu acho que tinha visto um vídeo
destes pelo Tik Tok o meu Deus ele deu
um no bloco lá em cima um cavalo que
anda na água do vídeo vocês tenham visto
isto ao vivo em qualquer lugar do mundo
isso não existe como é que aí afundou
mesmo eu pensei que fosse um pouco de
terra embaixo não não não Isto é
inexplicável e Sobrenatural isto na na
Ok temos um elástico três lápis que é
que vai sair daqui ó
e como é que eu nunca pensei nisso sério
a pessoas Geniais nunca pensei nisso
para copiar desenho nunca não é muito
inteligente What the f*** para o outro
asiática a limpar o chão incrível como é
que ela fez isso aí ela pega água e mete
napa meus pai para por lixo sólido por
isso ó temos aqui um gato uma pipoca não
é um gato um esquilo Alvin esquilo isto
o que saltos Salto do Sasuke não mas
isso aqui animal é um macaco lemur
suricata sem lá galinha olha esqueitista
caiu levante nesta edição não está
edição isso tem que ser edição Calma
calma botar a pensar em mim eu crio isso
levantou Ok próximo vídeo
Oi e esse leão em grande Olha aí Jeová
dele tem mais pelo do que é o três vezes
e outra no meio da cidade aquilo era no
meio da cidade ele vai passar em frente
viu que medo
e Como assim o fugiu do zoológico algo
assim ó celula.da medo assim iam à Solta
Ok um esquilo o que é que ele estava
fazer ele tava ter alguma coisa a água
Ah eu acho que isso eu já vi eu já vi
este vídeo ok vim no Tik Tok também ó
que fofo tá ver águinha é muito fofo
esquilo eu espero que ela esteja a fazer
isto antes da pandemia né porque vai que
tem lá vírus da língua de mutantes da
anonas coisas eu não confio Ok o quê que
ela está a fazer encostou cerveja no
comboio ai ela abriu cerveja não Ok meu
esses podia dar esse dente Não este
vídeo Eu vi este eu já Vita realmente
impressionante reparem só com o meu vai
cortar a maçã que não é uma maçã é um
bolo meus amigos e agora vai cortar a
mão e não é uma mão é um pouquinho bolo
como é que ele fez o meu até tentar tua
mão tentar tudo no bolo
o meu sério eu quando Viste na altura
achei muito impressionante Olha aí tá
muito real boate e teve um aspecto tem
bom expectorar um bolo tem chocolate tem
massa de açucar por fora chocolate
baunilha morango sei lá o que é que tem
mais tentar tu ainda por cima tem
estátua do vídeo você já tinha comido um
do outro lado eu nunca comi o bolo com
unha também que mesmo mora aí próximo Ok
temos uma pessoa em um metro e não isso
é muito louco é muito louco esse é louco
ele transformou a calça em calção velho
tem separa e tudo eu usei a não é isto é
fake vaco lá que a edição nota-se
claramente Mas é uma boa ideia Inclusive
eu acho que já tem em alguns países
projetos para desenvolver em carros
assim OK temos uma capa de iPhone um
corta laser
O que é uma capa né é uma capinha Ok
isso eu também já tinha visto por aí não
impressiona tanto e isto que um baloiço
I watch funciona sozinho é um banco com
balões aí que.
é isso eu deu soco Whats como é que eu
consegui salvar assim olha aí chinês a
fazer coisas chinês e
Eu acho que isso aqui até conseguir
fazer
eu acho que sim ai já não não isso é o
que lhe falta quantos degraus um dois
três quatro cinco só por seis degraus
para cima OK temos um bebé na água e ela
vai virar ei essa cabeça pesava não foi
ao fundo é assim que eles ensinam a
nadar não é jogador de basquete vôlei e
que ponto incrível Ok eu por trás das
costas não é a não não ele agarrou no
sexto e mandou por trás
e olha aí está bom que é isso dominadora
de vassoura 1
E aí
o Whats o peito tudo que é isto é o que
é um treinador de cães precisamente o
que tem que fazer ou não santo não
acredito ele passou os outros todos na
corrida ainda saltou era o que que ele
vai fazer a tuco tuco pé na água
e eu tenho demônio no corpo não acredito
neste
e levantou o peso com uma mão eu não sei
quando fez é que está ali mas de
qualquer forma com um braço só que é
isso helicóptero mano o que é que se faz
aqui busto
o outro fiz asiáticos Por que que eles
não mostram a queda por que que não
estragam a queda dela quero ver a queda
eu preciso de ver tudo até o fim a isto
fez o círculo perfeito só com um braço
olha aí como é que é possível ficou
perfeito mesmo a a vocês verem não é
aquela não fazia não pode estragar uma
geração inteira sabe Ok este aqui tá
louco está está a fazer
a fazer flexão com a palma da mão Como
assim OK temos aqui um bebé para o
taperense porque quem que prende assim
um bebé
é bem mas ele parece feliz ele tá
contente né
não é fofo mas é estranho Aquilo é para
que este só comentem isto para que isto
é para manter o bebé a dormir e é isso
pessoal esta foi a compilação de coisas
que tu vais ver pela primeira vez que eu
acho que vai ser assim tipo já sabem
deixem muito like aqui nesse vídeo
partilhem com os vossos amigos e é isso
pessoal fica bem até a próxima
[Música]
E aí